Databases must store sensitive data,
and there must be something different
about securing data that is stored in
a database compared to what
we've been talking about before.
So what we discussed before is
data stored in files, for example.
When we did access control we said you
have read/write permissions on files.
Databases we're going to
discuss are somewhat different.
They also store data, but
it's different and the fact that they
store lots of data that is sensitive,
that's what makes this topic important.
So databases actually do store
massive amounts of sensitive data.
This could be, if you are a company,
could be your customer data.
In fact, when we talk about some company
getting hacked and large amounts
of their customer data, such as social
security number, or date of birth, or
address, credit card numbers,
when those are being stolen by hackers,
databases store data that we can see
needs to be accessed in a certain way.
And the reason we're able to
do that is because databases
can store what is called
data in a structured form.
And the kind of examples that I just
talked about, the data that we have
about customer records or health
records, that data does have structure,
and the structure actually influences
how it's going to get accessed.
So, I may ask, for example, information
about all customers who purchased some
number of things in the last two months.
Asking this kind of a query or
formulating this king of a query or
a question That we want to
run against the database,
we make use of the structure that
is there in this data to do that.
So, it really do is that think about
a database storing structure data and
then we can basically access it through
programs called queries
that we submit to it.
These programs are queries written
in a language that is designed for
accessing data stored in databases.
One common one is SQL, which stands for
Structured Query Language.
So we're going to talk about accessing
data from databases using SQL
quite a bit.
This is another thing that is
different about databases.
Databases also store data that
is persistent, like files.
And of course we need
integrity of the data.
One way to do that is we
have this transactional
nature of queries of programs
that we run on the database.
A transaction means either
the program runs completely,
does everything it's supposed to do,
or whatever it did gets undone.
Transaction either,
we have the zero or one property,
either it's done completely or
not done at all kind of a thing.
By running a partial transaction,
for example,
a query could leave the database in
a state where it is not consistent and
that impacts the integrity.
Finally database is another thing that's
kind of different about them is that
we can create a virtual database,
what is called a database view.
This is really derived data
that's there in the database.
So for example, you may want to choose a
subset of the information that's stored
in the database.
So you can run a query against
the database, and the result
could be another sort of virtual
database, also called a database view.
And then users can have
access to that view.